hey guys it's abby sharp as you probably
know if you're watching my channel today
i'm gonna do a vlog unlike you know most
my videos i don't really have a plan for
this one i'm just going to be super raw
and open let you into my life a little
bit i feel like it's time to be super
real and the focus of this video i want
to be on my breastfeeding weaning
experience because that is really all
that i can focus on right now today's
monday and last week including up to
like sunday was world breastfeeding week
and it's ironic that it was world
breastfeeding week and i was obviously
thinking about breastfeeding a lot it
was ironic because
maybe one of the last times i was going
to breastfeed and that's because i'm in
the process of weaning my son
o
is almost 1 years old we're about like
10 days out from him being one our
breastfeeding journey has been really
beautiful but also you know just sadness
at the marking of the end of a stage and
looking forward to the future and i'm
hoping i can take you along with me with
all of the things that i want to
accomplish in this new phase of my life
so here's two new beginnings and
very sore clogged ducts please god do
not let me get mastitis this week but
first let me drop in here to tell you
what my sponsor drop okay i see what you
did there so if coveted life taught me
anything it's that online shopping is
super convenient time saving and very
fun and well also if you ask my husband
maybe a little bit dangerous for my
wallet as well but now that we're almost
like two years into this thing
i've had to find some easy ways like
downloading the drop app to save a buck
or earn some free money so drop is a
free shopping rewards app that gives you
cash back for shopping at all of your
favorite stores when you buy things that
you were already going to buy
so the way it works is that you download
the app link your debit or credit card
and earn points simply by shopping at
all of your favorite stores both in
person and on the app and then you can
redeem those points for some free gift
cards at places like amazon starbucks
uber and many more so for example i
recently got a bunch of points on my
instacart purchase which i obviously was
going to make every single week anyways
and for those of you who actually leave
the house you can also just show up in
person to the store and make your
purchases using the card that you linked
to your drop app and it will
automatically give you the points in
your account every time you shop at that
store in other words you don't have to
scan any receipts or clip any coupons it
just automatically will send points
right to your account you can also earn
points just by playing games or taking
surveys so you don't even have to shop
if you don't want to and then once
you've saved up enough points you can
redeem them for completely free gift
cards basically all the things that i
spend my paycheck on anyway i'm now
getting rewarded for so if you want to
kickstart your reward earnings today
check out my link in the description to
download drop in the app store or google
play and use my code abby to get a free
10 bonus in the form of 10 000 points
after you earn your first 1000 points so
i feel like i take one step forward and
two steps back literally every other day
so i've got days where i can go the
whole day and my boobs don't feel full
and then i just need to feed or pump at
the end of the day and that's like i was
getting really excited i was feeling
like we were finally making progress and
then we have a day like today where oh
decides to face plant into a toy bus as
he's trying to kind of crawl slash walk
he ends up like getting a bloody mouth
and a big swollen lip and he like cries
for 20 minutes crying then creates a
letdown and the left down makes my boobs
fill up with milk and now i have a clog
duct and that's how i got mastitis like
last week so i'd really like to not have
mastitis again but then the problem is
when i get a clogged duct then i need to
either feed him or nurse to clear it out
and then it just reinforces it's a cycle
and then i just produce more milk so
then i need to pump or feed again later
on in the day you can see how i'm taking
one step forward two steps back i think
my goal for today despite the fact that
i have a clogged duck and i'm in a lot
of pain is i just need to try to hold
off until the end of the day so that i
can just feed him once or pump once i
just need to hold strong on this and to
accept the pain and discomfort and know
that hopefully this is a short-lived
process last night i gave oh a little
bedtime nurse after he had his like full
bottle because i had that big clog in my
breast and i just like needed him to
suck it out and he did a good job thanks
thank you oh and then i pumped
afterwards and this is all i got this is
it yeah we're near the end and i feel so
bittersweet about it it's like on the
one hand i see this and i'm like yeah
just one ounce like maybe i could skip
that today and be done and free and then
on the other hand i'm like oh my gosh
like i gotta hold on to this i've spent
so many years and so long and so much
energy just trying to make more breast
milk the thought of never doing this
ever again is so frightening to me and i
don't know who i'm going to be at the
end of this or in this next chapter and
i'm just starting to realize that i feel
like this is probably what parents go
through at every
like monumental stage in their kids
lives like when they go to college it's
like you're excited about
that and you're so happy for that next
chapter of their lives but you're also
just so devastated you feel
like a death of that stage in parenthood
in your relationship together
it's tuesday morning and it's 9 a.m and
i might just slip a little some
something into my
coffee and it's not going to be this
milk
i'm feeling kind of down
like i'm feeling
the hormone crash and that's leaving me
feeling like a little bit depressed try
not to use that
term loosely but i do feel just down and
not excited about the future and i think
that that's quite common for folks when
they stop breastfeeding because the
oxytocin and the prolactin levels like
crash and tank and those are like your
love hormones and your calming hormones
so i just have this like uneasiness in
my body that i can't quite put my finger
on but i just know i don't feel
like myself i realize that i've spent
the last
four and a half almost five years of my
life
completely devoted to anybody but me
can't love yourself
how in the hell are you going to
so i've either been trying to get
pregnant through an ivf then being
pregnant and or you know having
miscarriages and then becoming actually
pregnant and staying pregnant and then
breastfeeding or pumping and i'm just
like it's time that i do something
for me so i think it's time that we do a
little glow-up and i'm not even talking
about doing like an inspirational glow
up like glow up from the inside out kind
of thing i'm just talking about like a
super trashy
frivolous
superficial glow up here like those 90s
movies where they would do a makeover on
the geeky girl and then suddenly all the
guys would want her that's what i'm
gonna do right now let's do a makeover
oh
no i have lived in these nursing bras
for
like four years and i am so excited to
never see them again
yes queen
bye-bye
this
represents
a lot of sadness a lot of pain but also
a lot of hope bittersweet to see this
one go but also probably should get the
sharps
out of my house so just got out of the
shower
took a quick little look-see in the
mirror here tmi but i feel like it's
time to invest in some really good
push-up bras because
your girls
are not living their best life anymore
it is amazing how quickly things change
yeah that's the trade-off you lose your
boobs but you get your freedom back
nothing that a good bra can't fix glow
up check in folks um
see what that is
oh yeah
a bra and not one of the ones that kind
of clasp and flap open to expose your
boobie a real bra a bra
that doesn't make my boobies look flat
okay folks i have to tell you about this
because i'm really excited but also very
nervous because i'm a bit of a prude but
one of the things that i've always been
most excited about and most anticipating
as i
end this season of my life of being
pregnant and trying to conceive and
breastfeeding is i really wanted to
experiment with cbd and thc not smoking
it because like i feel like i have a
little bit of ptsd from high school i
just want to experiment now that it's
legal here in canada so many of my
friends have found relief by taking
edibles or tinctures with thc and cbd
for anxiety insomnia depression etc i
struggle i struggle quite a bit i really
want to see if this is something that
can help me definitely want to put out a
huge disclaimer that i i am not an
expert in cannabis education this is out
of the scope of anything i can recommend
so i'm absolutely not recommending it
for anyone but it's just been something
that i wanted to try for my own self and
my own kind of anxiety and insomnia
healing journey and yeah i guess see
how it goes life update
i feel like that one actually worked um
not sure if i slept because it was the
right
magical blend
or if it's because of the fact that i
have not slept in like a week and it was
about time but regardless i thought hey
why not celebrate
with some shopping got me some new jeans
and i don't have like non-skinny jeans
so i feel like these are my first pair
of
cool gem zed jeans to go with my my
middle part
feeling young
that's what this is all about folks
these are super comfortable
i can't really see them here but yes
three quarter length not sure
when it's appropriate here in canada to
wear three-quarter length but they were
so comfortable i just had to buy them
anyway so we're gonna make it work this
how cute yeah i basically bought this
because it's green and
i'm having a birthday party for my
little baby on the weekend and
it's green and gold themed because it's
a tractor theme it's a farm theme so i
figured this would be like farm chic
we're going for it okay how cute is this
top because it's comfortable it's like
jersey cotton i don't know i don't think
about fabrics but
super
feminine but still comfortable okay
likewise
comfortable
but pretty and i love the color such a
pretty color oh
shopping makes you feel good doesn't it
we're going for it
all right here's the beauty master aaron
hey so we're just getting my hair done
in my garage as people do during covet
apparently so yeah i'm looking forward
to seeing how this looks and this is the
after shot we're living her best hair
life
and you are too doing hair in a garage
how glamorous we're so glamorous we're
luxury ladies luxurious yes well i'm
definitely feeling better so thank you
so much aaron call me vayne but i gotta
say sometimes just having somebody else
curl your hair is enough to just totally
uplift your day and i totally believe
that confidence comes from the inside
obviously not from aesthetic features
like your hair
but sometimes you gotta fake it till you
make it if having freshly
washed woe
and colored and curled hair
makes me feel like a little bit more of
a badass and just gives me that boost of
energy that i'm being so badly lacking
during covid as a pregnant nursing mama
feels like a good investment to me
today is
my little baby oh's birthday and
tomorrow's birthday party and i gotta
tell you i woke up this morning from a
damn good sleep and i feel
so
so happy i feel like most of my friends
always get to the one year mark and they
feel very emotional they're like my
baby's growing up my baby doesn't need
me and i totally
can appreciate that sentiment i feel
like every phase of our children's lives
is so exciting and everything has its
pros and cons if you were to ask me if i
like being pregnant i'ma tell you
no i love that my eldest e i love that
he can say the damn cutest things
hilarious things he can communicate me
in the most intellectual intelligent way
in a way that i'm like how the [ __ ] do
you even know anything about that
and i'm so excited for oh to be able to
do the same and for the two of them to
like go off on each other because
they're already best friends and
honestly there's nothing more fulfilling
than that for me to watch as a parent so
i'm just so excited for this new season
of motherhood okay so update it's been a
week and
i got some really great advice i have a
colleague who's a registered dietitian
who specializes in cannabis education so
she knows her stuff she's written a book
and i read it and i really just want to
engross myself in as much information as
i possibly could i
spent
a couple hundred bucks on a variety of
different blends and
i finally found one that actually is
working for me and i'm so excited i
don't know if it's psychosomatic i don't
know if it's just the weight of the
whole breastfeeding thing
is off my shoulders and that is also
causing me and helping me to relax a
little bit
but whatever it is
i'm gonna hold on to this for dear life
because
it's been several years since i have
slept
through the night and woken up feeling
well rested so yeah i am feeling pretty
damn good
and i want to
[Music]
got me celebrate down
[Music]
so yesterday was oh's birthday party we
had a big kind of soiree for him with
all the neighborhood kids outside
benefits of a summer baby like i woke up
so happy
that i made it that i survived through
the baby phase i just feel like my
family is complete and i don't have to
be pregnant again i don't have to do ivf
again i don't necessarily breastfeed if
i don't want it again i'll never have to
pump again yeah so i woke up and i was
like
i was like vibing with myself i was
feeling so good and i just took a
piece of
leftover birthday cake out of the
freezer
and i'm gonna eat this for breakfast so
how can you not be happy it is
10 a.m and i just dropped my kid off at
school and i thought you know we just
had this birthday party so i have a ton
of adult beverages leftover so i thought
i'd give one of them a try
oh gotta love the sound of a can opening
now this is either going to be really
good or
really bad smells like watered down wine
tastes like juice that's better
i've had a pretty productive day it's
friday right now when i'm filming this
and i always film my videos when i can
on friday mornings and i've tried
especially in the summer months to kind
of take the afternoons to be you know
hanging out with the kids i'm just
picking e up from summer camp but
because i literally ran out the door
like i film this finished filming my
last video and i was like oh i gotta go
i gotta pick up the kiddo didn't have
time to pack much of a picnic lunch so
starbucks to the rescue right a little
snack box action did you chase did you
chase the girls you didn't throw all
that dirt and stuff at them did you
i did the boys don't like to have stuff
thrown at them but the girls do
we got some work to do the first thing
on our to-do list is to have our park
picnic so we're gonna have our parking
picnic we're gonna have our our quiet
time then we're gonna have our tv time
okay so while the kids are playing and
i'm trying to keep an eye i don't know
if you guys follow me on instagram if
you don't you should at abby's kitchen
and on fridays i always do like a ask
abby anything series and it's become a
bit of a friday uh tradition and i don't
think i've skipped one for a while a
long time follow me over there if you
want to get your questions answered but
anyways it's just like a fun little way
to wrap up the week well this was
officially like my most
random video
of life but i think it nicely
encompasses the messy metamorphosis that
i'm experiencing
as i send off summer and welcome this
new phase of motherhood now i want to
reiterate that while i chose to and i
wanted to wean and i feel that i'm done
having babies i do not want to insinuate
that i feel that any stage of motherhood
is a handicap in general i really think
this is such a beautiful phase of life
and also one that i'm so grateful that i
got to experience especially because i
struggled so much to actually get
pregnant and also to breastfeed as well
so this was such a true gift for me but
i am ready for this new phase and i'm
just also so excited to embrace the
adventure and focus on a little more
self-care and fun so i hope that you
guys enjoyed seeing some of these fun
family memories as much as i enjoyed
making them if you liked this video be
sure to give it the thumbs up
leave me a comment below on what you'd
like to see me vlog next subscribe to
the channel and i'll see you next time
on abby's kitchen
bye
[Music]
you